yeah uh first over-the-board tournament
did you enjoy it i did oh but as you're
saying it's a big big venue where a lot
of people are sitting so the air quality
there was oh really bad yeah
and only boys you know yeah they want to
call right
all right well game three uh started
david what are we seeing it's another
sicilian defense this time slightly less
cagey than the first game of today it's
the open sicilian jana panetti going on
the attack early and this last pawn move
by white pushing upon the white cheep on
forward shows his aggression
but magnus reacts instantly this is the
height of opening fashion this is one of
the most trendy uh lines most trendy
variations in chess right now we saw
trade of knights white uh black pushing
a pawn forward now white is the first to
castle black really needs to catch up on
peace development though if you look at
all of black's king side pieces all of
the pieces on this side of the board
they're still asleep they're still at
home so white will love to maybe push
all the pawns forward and initiate an
attack at some point i think this is a
great opening choice though in a must
win almost must win situation and uh
what i really like about napolita's
choice is that uh we're actually
following a game that nils grandelius
played against magnus carlson in
vikensei this year so that was literally
in january and uh well that means that
the pomegranate has some preparation at
hand
and uh that opening between neil's
grandelias who actually used to work for
magnus carlsen used to be one of his
coaching team
uh that opening led to a white advantage
a big big white advantage uh grandelias
had magnus on the ropes in that one
however i do happen to know that magnus
mixed up his move order in that game he
prepared very very deeply he studied
i think past move 20. he just mixed up
the move order and that's why he was in
trouble so will magnus maybe come up
with an improvement on that game will he
try and throw napomiacci off the scent
early by springing a surprising move now
um either way i still like the strategy
by napoli actually i think at least
magnus will have to be super accurate to
survive this opening just look at the
black pieces
he needs to bring them out he does he
leaps out with the black knight and
white just guards two pawns with what
this last push and this is napomniachi's
improvement he actually had this
position
this variation with white in the ftx
crypto cup uh the knockout portion
against fabiano caruana and that game
ended in a draw i think
if i get my
stats yeah draw and uh now instead of
just pushing the g pawn up and attacking
the knight he's like no no no i'm going
to reinforce my pawn structure in the
center okay so clearly something napoli
actually has studied recently maybe part
of his preparation for the world
championship match maybe he just looked
at it this morning but either way it
will be fresher in his mind than magnus
carlsen's mind most likely this isn't
magnus's main line despite the fact he
had it uh just last month against nils
grandelius magnus only tends to go to
this
opening in situations where he is
embracing the fight
that's why i'm surprised a draw would be
a great result for him he's not trying
to lock it down with the petrov defense
the berlin defense something uh that we
as commentators maybe are reluctant to
see instead he's
uh putting on the show and fighting fire
with fire one thing that's super
interesting is actually you know when
i've looked through the games i always
see one name that stands out that magnus
is uh has been following and it's always
jordan van forest he was his second in
the world championship match i'm like oh
yeah one game in my database ah look
who's played it with the black pieces
you're done look who's played it with
the white pieces you you don't run for
it so it seems like uh magnus has been
really impressed with the young dutchman
yeah um we talked about air quality but
georgian van ferest i think he was a
breath of fresh air for the uh magnus
team at the world championship match we
know that in 2018 magnus employed daniel
dubov who kind of gave him new ideas on
chess and the same happened with jordan
van forst this year or well last year
during the world championship match so
okay black's knight kicked to the side
of the board now and white's queen
stepping back that's actually a bit of a
defensive move white's queen could get
hit uh over the next few turns it would
have had to step back anyway so they're
probably actually just preempting that
expecting that in advance and stepping
back with his queen also the weapon
guarding some of the pawns on this queen
side where the white king stands
we might well see opposite side castling
here as well like throwing everything
towards the white king and white doing
the same against the black king at the
moment though black's king stranded in
the middle of the board well remember
everyone this is the last day of the
tournament and you can win a tour
badge so we do have one badge for each
of the tournaments in the season well
water champions chess tour
and you can actually win a badge by
playing in
the tour badges leaderboard and if you
use the code that you see in the bottom
of the screen right now you can go
premium with a 50 discount so head into
chess24 to uh check that out and david i
guess you have to pay
extra
um
you know look at this game uh in
particular because i did hear
nails grandelious mentioned and how many
days until you face him oh not many now
i think just five days until like five
days in london yeah uh it's on wednesday
we start so
someone else can do the math four or
five days and uh yeah i'll be back at
the board yes oh i'm so much looking
forward to that so it's a 10
game match
it's basically the world championship
match just with lower stakes lower price
money slightly lower rated players but
just as much on earth exactly more honor
on the line yeah
niels grandelius of course worked with
magnus carlsen swedish number one for
years already uh for number two
scandinavian player and uh yeah it's
gonna be a battle
it's a friend of mine as well and it's
hard to play against friends i don't
know about how you feel but
playing against someone you like someone
you know inside out
a lot of psychology behind it yeah
absolutely and we play a lot of friends
in the good night so
we uh get used to each other's openings
and yeah that's true that makes it
difficult to like prepare because
we always meet the same yeah and then
we used to do alternating moves which is
like family chess you have to oh you
have a partner basically i like that
kind of chess yeah it's fun it's nice
because uh
it makes it more interesting and you see
moves that are not really common
it makes it more fun yeah yeah
yeah oh sorry i was just going to say
that's one of my dreams on maybe a
future edition of future series uh one
year of the championship to see pears
chess doubles chess mixed doubles for
example you could see magnus paired up
with one of the top women players in the
world and alternating moves to see
whether their styles match or collide or
whether
they kind of i don't know players might
get angry with each other their
teammates finding it out you said you
played this with your husband ivanka it
can be really uh difficult yeah extra
challenging but also entertaining from
your hands
entertaining i remember once in 2008 um
there was an international mind sports
olympiad and um
there was there was this option of
pear's chest but no no one really knew
what it was i remember david's mom
because david was very young came up to
me and said david wants to play in this
olympiad do you want to be his partner
for pearce and i was like absolutely
[Laughter]
yeah so cool it was it was uh yeah so we
didn't do the past chess but it kind of
was different it was basically a man and
a woman playing as a team together and
uh it was because my partner wasn't the
strongest uh player there so he was
often the target so like people were
playing very solidly against me and then
how are you playing him yeah so it was
kind of experienced but uh i do i just
wanted to go back to the whole playing
the friends yeah so i have one
philosophy that so basically chess is
chess life is life but i do have one
guideline which is you don't play dirty
against friends so so for instance you
know it was a completely level position
so you know it's completely drawn and
maybe your friend has like 10 seconds on
the clock and you have 15 seconds on the
clock don't try and flag them okay
that's this going to be that's going to
ruin the friendship you're too nice to
vancouver i would do anything to be
different
no no no no
it's uh but sportsmanship it's important
right yeah yeah and okay napoli actually
just lent back there kind of widening
his eyes at this last move by magnus you
talked about targeting partners
targeting
pieces here is uh is the name of the
game and magnus carlsen right now has
hit the white knight but
it looks a bit scary for black this
white knight after this pawn push is uh
is attacked it needs to move but you can
step it back in actually any direction
it's tempting to put it on the side of
the board normally knights on the room
are dim but this knight can even leap
forward later on to attack the black
rook and this square actually maybe a
launch pad for a future attack by
white's knight or white bishop he
doesn't do this he plays the safer
option and uh talking of targeting
pieces the white knight was the target
now the black knight on the side of the
board is the big big target white's next
move is nearly definitely going to be
this one with his bishop hitting this
black knight and where is this black
knight going to run to that is the issue
for magnus
for example if he plays the move that he
wants to
breaking out in the center of the board
just to gain some space just to fight
against white center i think uh this
will be ignored
this bishop move hitting the black
knight is going to cause all sorts of
trouble black has to now just defend it
with the pawn but this pawn structure
for black now it's doubled pawns but
also a very open kingside means that
black will never surely castle on this
side it's just gonna end in checkmate
it's gonna end
in disaster so really scary position for
magnus despite the evaluation bar
thinking he's okay black is the one who
has to be more careful and there we go
the evaluation by actually shooting off
in white's favor after crunching the
numbers maybe the horizon of the
computer going a bit further seeing that
black is in trouble in the current
position this is a huge strategic threat
hitting the knight on the edge of the
board yeah interestingly enough we're
still following that game that jordan
van forest played with the black pieces
there he was playing against sir
viswanathan anand and
i kid you not
he
actually won in a very similar manner to
how you highlight it yeah so this looks
very logical i mean totally for example
i mean i'm struggling to find a move if
black does this just to reinstate uh
kind of restate the point yes black
can't castle on this side but at some
point white is simply going to move the
knight over take this pawn and then jump
even further towards the black king
black is just really weak on the dark
squares and it's surprising to me that
magnus has gone into this position
walked into it willingly a position
maybe he should be aware of because it
has been played by one of his seconds
and look at the clock time he's not
happy he's spent almost half his time
now no pogchi still clearly in his
opening preparation up over 15 minutes
actually gaining time from when he
started and yeah in the current position
it's all about this move but it's just
unstoppable and it's going to be very
very dangerous for black to meet
wow
all right well magnus carlsen if he wins
this game he's going to be the winner
jana pomnyacci needs at least a draw and
he does uh need to win either this game
or the next one to take it to toy breaks
and i guess then it's looking good for
him so far this could be the game he
makes that comeback yeah i just think a
great opening choice um when you need to
win it's nice to have these imbalances
and look at this actually exactly what i
showed on the board has just happened
black did try and challenge in the
center this is thematic in the sicilian
when you're on the black side you want
to explode open the center of the board
but now after the bishop hit the knight
it was defended and this exchange this
trade favors white
so right now still some light uh still
some hope for black if he can open up
this bishop along this diagonal for
example if we see some porn trades in
the center of the board but i think if
white is accurate then we will not
actually see that happen i mean white
can even lock it down completely in the
center block it up push this pawn
forward it looks like a
porn blunder but actually this would
walk into a skewer on this diagonal when
the black queen moves the black rook in
the corner would drop off uh so okay he
doesn't even feel the need to block it
up maybe being more ambitious than the
punishing he brings his knight in
already going for this isolated doubled
weak pawn on the edge of the board and
from there he'll jump in towards the
black king
it's sharpening up and i can actually
see that this has kind of been analyzed
in july 2021 but it didn't look good for
black
okay so it's been analyzed this would be
a real disaster from magnus carlsen
walking into a variation that is known
and okay the evaluation by saying black
is fine ish now
but from a practical point of view
unless he's 100 sure i think he's going
to walk into danger this black king
stuck in the middle is going to be
stranded there for a long long time
and i'm probably actually looking off to
the side a moment ago
is that his recall face if it just feels
to me as if he may have studied this
position before or at least something
very similar to it
um as ivanka mentioned this has been
played before
much of this line and he will be aware
of the ideas at least yeah i mean
this kind of reminds me of a lesson that
happened to me many years ago when i
played well i faced a very sharp opening
against the karakan and i didn't know my
theory and i lost
very quickly and
what happened yeah
yeah jan playing a very surprising move
actually hitting the black queen with
the white bishop but this can be blocked
by a porn move i'm wondering if the
evaluation bar will correct itself
yeah i mean this still feels super sharp
and to me yanaponechi may be still in
preparation so okay yeah that evaluation
bar let's ignore it for now it's going
to swing and swing and swing as it has
done throughout the whole final
yesterday and today
um yeah so a human move yeah it's a very
human move i think we'll see some
fireworks and there are some ideas
behind it i think jan is actually
getting ready for some really surprising
sacrifices we'll show it if it happens
on the board
yeah no i was just going to say if
you're going to play sharp variations
know your stuff that's it you know
yeah inside out when it comes to your
opening repertoire and you have a very
solid one but there's like a few lines
that are critical
those are the ones you need to know and
uh here you don't go into this
blindfolded so to speak you know you've
got to know your way around those these
positions because it's just razor sharp
you know look at black's king it could
with you know if magnus plays a big
blunder he could be checkmated any time
now yeah and maybe we can show because
actually one of the most obvious moves
in this position is a huge blunder this
queen is attacked by white's bishop and
if you step forward with a pawn to block
this attack white is just gonna say okay
i don't care about pieces i need to open
up lines towards the black king white is
just gonna take this pawn sacrifice the
bishop and once the queen comes out
white will just slide across with his
rook and uh actually maybe even more
powerful is to give a check first and
once the king moves now slide across
with the rook and look at the power of
the white rooks here this rook
this rook the white queen is going to
hit both these bishops
everything is falling for black and
worst of all it's going to end in
checkmate maybe you lose the queen and
then your king will be the next target
so i don't think magnus can open things
up by blocking this attack
to his queen he needs to move his queen
out of this diagonal but the question is
where if you are careless and put it on
the wrong square white's queen will
still jump up with a check supported by
its rook down here and black will be in
huge trouble uh so you need to move your
queen and you need to defend this square
that the white queen wants to use with a
check if you step it up the board maybe
the white bishop sneaks in as well look
at these dark squares how weak are they
black cannot castle on that side it's
just that would be suicidal right now
it's too open
just looked like huge trouble for magnus
maybe just by process of elimination he
needs to step the queen back to
challenge the white queen just to gain a
bit of time i don't think white wants to
trade queens white wants to give
checkmate but then again once the white
queen moves still an attack against this
queen gaining time now for white and
this looks
super scary and that's an understatement
uh i think black is in big practical
trouble okay he does drop back with his
queen uh now he wants to trade off so
black's queen threatening to capture the
white queen but white's queen is just
going to move out of the way
and napoleon will continue the attack
and magnus is almost 10 minutes down on
the clock how rare is that
yeah and
the community has just under 15 minutes
you know he's
almost the same time that he started
with which is a great news for
nepomnierci's fans
um
and i don't like also to top it all off
i really don't like magnus's position
and he doesn't like it either you can
just tell by his body language that
yeah this has gone wrong
i think even if he saves this game
magnus carlsen he will look back at this
as a bit of an opening disaster he's
just been out prepared yannick clearly
when he gets back to the board he'll
play another quick move i expect but
he's clearly in his preparation he's
clearly studied this or something
similar before
magnus unfamiliar with the ideas
uncomfortable being attacked and also
last season of the champions chess tour
when magnus eventually triumphed the
only times he ever really lost games was
by a direct attack against his king it's
all to do with king safety he nearly
never loses an end game he nearly never
gets kind of tricked
in simple positions it's only when his
king is the big target and here the
black king is the big target
in the middle of the board this feels
like
for example a duboff game from the white
side so far it's just about whether
yanaponechi can eventually trap that
black king
but no queen traits i think that's the
only prediction i'm making so far white
will avoid this trade if you were
playing this katrina with the black
pieces would you uh be scared right now
would you be you know
screaming out on your stream and feeling
like this is going all wrong yeah like i
think for me playing
this position i think it wouldn't happen
because i don't play the sicilian very
often
but um
just one of the first moves he made with
this night like i wouldn't move my
knight out just because i saw that the
pawn was coming but he was like okay
i'll go for it the the pawn can be
pushed in the g file and my knight is on
the f file but that's okay like i
wouldn't be brave enough to do that
and to play these positions i think i
would be too
stressed like uh
i don't know you have to have like
as we say in norway ice in your tummy
yeah yeah
yeah these two definitely have ice in
their tummy and just judging by this
final they've been playing such brave
chess but sometimes as you mentioned
brave chess can backfire and
right now for magnus he was super brave
in the opening going into this kind of
double-edged complex fight but that's
not what he needed in the match
situation he was already one point up
so uh okay what will jan do next this
last bishop move by magnus at least
makes a lot of sense he's plugged this
open d file so he's blocked the attack
from the white rook to the black queen
yeah and uh okay the clock time though
still very worrying
yeah and one thing i wanted to mention
about this uh bishop move that magnus
has played i mean
apart from blocking the uh the open d
line it also you know maybe magnus can
entertain some ideas of doing a
counter-attack you know bringing the
queen out to the edge of the board so
the queen and bishop can start looking
at little alice sitting on a2
and maybe there's some counter play
there but of course the primary issue is
black's king safety
yeah that's true actually uh at least it
will scare napoleon slightly it will put
the fear of ghosts into him uh because
the white king doesn't have too many
defenders either
and uh katrina how would you
characterize your style of play you're
mentioning you're not liking to get
attacked in these situations
i think that i still follow a lot of the
principles that the new players do like
try to castle within the ten moves
and
i am still aggressive like when i play
i usually go and try to mate on age
seven
they're bringing of just trying to give
yes
and we actually did that against ivanka
and uh we played you and simon and rayne
on the good night once and we had this
position we'll be attacking your your
king's side yeah
[Laughter]
chest i i really think it's fun um i'm
trying to get more positional when it
comes to understanding why so it's like
at me and why is this not
and
trying to get more to the working games
as i said i don't get to them often and
so now i see that it's really
really important because in the
classical games that i had i actually
lost a few games that was a theoretical
draw but i didn't know how to hold it
with a rook against a pawn yeah we both
had a rook and he had one porn and it
was a theoretical draw i know that now
is that something you've actively worked
on since your first over-the-board
experience yeah so i had some of my
friends help me understand how is this
uh what happened to the boy yeah i mean
it's a bit of a strange decision by uh
nepalishi i have to say while you guys
are talking because he just came in and
jumped
with his knight gave a check
but after bishop takes night pawn takes
uh
pawn takes bishop then uh
black is not obliged to capture the pawn
yeah i'm just wondering as well ivanka
you touched on the term counter-attack
now might be the moment for black to
counter-attack um if we pull up the
board let's keep an eye on the players
we might see a big reaction from jan if
magnus plays okay he just brings his
rook across firstly as ivanka mentioned
queen takes pawn was a bad move because
now the bishop would actually hit the
queen and hit the rook behind it in the
corner so magnus is preparing this by
just shuffling his rook across putting
it on a light square
that's important because now we'll never
get hit by the white bishop but i was
about to say
maybe there's something even better
maybe the black queen could have jumped
to the side of the board hitting this
pawn with the queen with the bishop and
suddenly white is the one under attack
white's king is under fire and if the
pawn steps up just to block this
bishop's diagonal then there are ideas
such as sacrificing this rook
this is quite a typical theme uh in very
uh specific situations where
your opponent's king has no defenders
and after the king steps forward taking
this rook suddenly the queen comes down
hitting the king now and maybe the only
way to survive is to march into the
center of the board but the white king
would be under serious pressure here
this is still in the air but magnus
instead taking a quieter option and not
going for the white king immediately not
going for the counter attack by bringing
his queen out instead just shuffling his
rook across and the reason the
evaluation bar doesn't like this is
because white's knight was maybe the
best attacker white's knight could have
maybe been the one delivering the killer
blow to the black king now it's opposite
color bishops but as long as black
controls the light squares white will
not be able to break through on that
color complex and actually this one pawn
holds everything together um it's going
to take ages for white's queen to sneak
into the position now without the knight
white's queen is the only one that can
deliver checkmate but she's a mile away
from doing that well from a human
perspective and also looking at the
clocks david do you agree with the bar
um i'm surprised it's that fine black's
favor but the momentum has changed for
sure it was like he'd listen to you yeah
just when you said that okay okay well
i'm gonna listen to david yeah
it's it's mainly because i don't see any
follow-through for white now and also if
we do a quick count black is a pawn up
after all so that's why plus one for
black does make some sense and the
evaluation bar just reflecting the
material on the position and if you look
at the pawn next to the white queen in
any end game black will be winning
because that pawn is two squares away
from promotion so black has that in his
pocket magnus knows any queen trade will
favor black yeah and it's nice to have
these kind of long term and short-term
goals in mind yeah i'm so shocked at
that move actually because um
like david kind of highlighted the queen
and bishop in order for this to be an
effective strategy the queen and bishop
need to be working really well targeting
that e7 square for first of all
they're not going to get that it's not i
mean you can't enter that it's just no
way so
where is white's counter-attacking
possibilities and like you say the more
pieces that get traded off
the more that pawn sitting on f3 is
going to become stronger and stronger
and it's something that magnus can
almost i kind of could use the word
bully can boolean upon me she was like
you want to try you know i'm going to
just trade pieces you want to make a
trade here you go and uh napomneshi will
have to keep declining that trade and
all magnus needs to do is get a safe
king
easy yeah
exactly if the queen's come off it's
just
all going to be about black and this
last move actually i've been looking at
it for a while i like it from magnus he
wants to bring the black rook down to
the g2 square to the second rank where
all of the white pawns are and it's
going to start picking off pawns
at the two black rooks on great open
lines white strokes meanwhile the one in
the corner not doing anything the other
one in the center blocked by a strong
fortified bishop
back in heaven
exactly second heaven um the second rank
for blacks rooks
i mean if they land there it's going to
be deadly and if white tries to
challenge for this g-file to try and
trade off the set of rooks black will
still plant his rook on the g2 square
and it's going to be really hard for
white to deal with
and magnus looking much more relaxed
than he did just two moves ago yeah he's
kind of escaped the worst of it and uh
this is this was actually something that
we saw in the world championship you
know a lot of commentators spoke before
the event that you know napoli's biggest
danger was this what they called the
glass jaw which is like a boxing term
you know that is fragile he gets hit he
doesn't get back up again and uh
it seems to be striking again
and it just seems to be like a super
sharp position and he tries to take the
most direct way and
it's not successful sometimes you should
be a little bit subtle
yeah in the last game his mistake came
after just 48 seconds of thinking and
then he made a nice sacrifice which
didn't work this one he made this night
check after a couple of minutes of
thinking
but it was the wrong decision and uh
maybe just at that critical moment
investing another two minutes would have
helped him uh find a stronger idea and
now the evaluation about really hating
white's position
wondering what's going to happen if
black's rook simply comes into the g2
square as predicted
it's suddenly it's like i don't know
somehow chess is like this you know
like you're struggling you're struggling
all throughout the game and then your
opponent makes a mistake and suddenly
your pieces have found themselves in
great counter-attacking squares and the
rook that wasn't that effective is
suddenly can potentially line up with
its partner on the and they can hit
together the c2 square like david
highlighted the queen is primed to come
in and jump out of the right stage
and look at this bishop that he's
planted on the d5 square which primarily
was a defensive
purpose and now it can even sacrifice
okay and there you go the rook comes
into the second rank wow it's the best
move but it's also the most obvious move
so of course magnus was gonna find it
and the problem is these white pieces
they look great on these open lines but
they can't break through they're hitting
against uh concrete here they're hitting
against granite this pawn is so well
defended for black and this bishop
defended by the black queen we should
mention another tempting move maybe for
viewers at home would have been queen
takes pawn it looks like you can grab a
second pawn for free but now rook takes
bishop would be possible because the
queen no longer defending this bishop
and this pawn in the center is pinned it
cannot recapture because of a line
towards it from the white queen so this
would have been a mistake but magnus of
course would have spotted that and
bringing his rook in hitting a really
tender spot in white's camp suddenly the
white king which looks super safe having
three pawns shelter in front of it is
not feeling too good because if for
example black gets another move two
rooks on the second rank this is just
going to be disaster the black rooks are
going to crash through and deliver a
nasty checkmate over the next few uh few
turns so yeah already dangerous for jan
and if he lifts his rook up which i
think he has to that only exchanges
pieces in the best world uh best of
worlds uh for example black can just do
nothing that can even just wait and if a
rook capture happens here look at this
pawn how strong is this tying down both
the whites queen and whites rook to this
promotion square yeah this one is
one-sided traffic right now and i think
jan is going to be
really regretting that night check
earlier he's just left black's rook into
the heart of his position and he has
gone under five minutes on the clock on
the pulmonary he cannot lose this game
if he does that magnus carlsen will be
the winner of the air things masters and
do you think that's now going to be the
case david after three games today yeah
um i'm struggling to find any active
ideas from yan uh he's shaking his head
now slightly as well
he does feel like we might not get a
game four i wanted to see game four
there's been so much excitement in every
single game but
magnus just
one chance he's he was given one chance
in the last game he seized it now one
chance in this game so far he's seized
it and
that's why he's the world champion he is
ruthless and meanwhile okay jan jumping
in with the queen that's brave
allowing blacks and rooks to come into
the position there is a threat from
white white actually wants to bring the
rook up and capture black's bishop in
the middle of the board because if the
black queen ever moves away white's
queen is going to zoom across step in
front of the black king and deliver
checkmate so some active ideas
but it feels like it shouldn't work
it feels like magnus should have
complete control can he just capture
this pawn with this rook
i'm working out i don't think he can
yeah stockfish the computer says black's
best move is just a calm solid defensive
move bringing the black queen down one
square and challenging white's queen on
the seventh rank a queen trade as we
mentioned will favor black black has
this monster pawn on the f3 square
that is logical but it's also tempting
to look for more aggressive moves so
that's the only thing that might trip up
magnus carlsen actually that queen move
devastating winning on the spot
but will he find it
it's also attempting to use one of the
black rooks and capture this pawn that
we mentioned on the c2 square but that
might backfire
so okay critical moment will magnus find
the best move everything else actually
lets white back into the game
what do we think should we have a bet
katrina
i think you'll find it i think it will
find it also and i i was thinking that
maybe uh because
in some of my games i had this
experience that
i make a move after like thinking for a
while
and then
seeing it and realizing right after
that was something i didn't think about
yeah and it seems like it happened to
napolita twice yeah
lightning does strike twice and okay
magnus of course finds the best move we
saw it yesterday several times if
there's only one move in the position or
if there's by far one move stronger than
all the others
he is likely to find it and he also
mentioned that phrase in his interview
yesterday process of elimination even
the top players do it they see all the
options they think okay this doesn't
work this doesn't work this one looks a
bit complicated they go for the final
option and often it's the best one
so magnus just offering this trade of
queens and
white's being forced back i loved that
interview with kaio yesterday when he
she asked him about this move that he'd
found and he just goes well of
it's like a process course
elimination like why wouldn't you find
it well well
it wasn't that obvious magnus
we in the studio myself uh ivanka simon
we were struggling to find it we thought
okay
it's so difficult i actually saw the
other broadcast uh with tanya satchev
and peter lecco they said it would be
inhuman to find it really and magnus
found it of course and in the interviews
like yeah yeah yeah just
it's normal
so yeah these players they are on
another level yeah and okay meanwhile
the queen trade would have favored black
because black does have this really
strong past pawn so white's queen
stepped back and jan exhaling deeply
there
actually he's i mean there's so many
tempting moves i'm looking at checks
first of all black has a very tempting
bishop takes pawn check just to lure out
the white king
and then some queen checks to follow up
i'm not sure that works instead he just
brings his rooks down and
second heaven has kaia coined those two
black rooks
that's just too strong just looks
completely winning for black yeah black
is going to take the pawn next to the
white king now and then take the other
pawn
how do you defend i mean can you just
ignore everything and just go queen
takes bishop and
yeah i think maybe he could have tried
that but i think there would have been
some checkmating ideas
um if that had happened so white
dropping back the bishop to defend the
pawn in front of the white king
but black is two pawns up now with the
attack
he just needs to be careful as ivanka
mentioned of threats like white's queen
taking the black bishop in front of it
utilizing a pin on the e-file but plus
30. wow wow normally we see plus three
or four or plus a hundred if this
checkmate but never plus 30 that means
there must be a win what is the win
right now for black
um
it must feature a check surely
it feels like there's something in the
air is the black bishop going to come
down and take a pawn with check
and black's rook sacrifice itself
black's queen can just move and keep
everything safe and i think black's
winning it anyway
but is there a killer bloke it's gone up
to plus a hundred for black wow means
there's checkmate in the position
okay
queen a4 maybe or bring it in like
yeah
yeah that's fine
i think you're right that's a great we
should show it yeah um okay let's
quickly show this before magnus uh finds
it in the current position if we just
catch up this was a couple of moves ago
now katrina's mentioning queen to a4
threatening checkmate in one hitting the
square with the queen and pawn and now
if the white queen steps up capturing
this bishop utilizing the fact it can't
be taken due to a pin here katrina the
killer blow
rook takes pawn right which takes pawn
that's a check guarded by this rook and
after bishop takes another check this is
nice black sacrificing a rook and a
bishop but delivering checkmate at the
very end
he's not gone for that i've gone for it
but maybe finding a different uh
different strong path magnus in the
current position taking this bishop and
now after king takes he's jumping in
with the black queen
still strong but
your move winning on the spot katrina i
think and now the white king is able to
hide in the corner maybe
and uh jan is he living to fight another
day or has magnus got a follow-up here
i think he's going to do katrina's idea
there we go there we go same idea and uh
yep
and again somehow a little bit meaner
[Laughter]
and again queen takes bishop runs into
queen check and checkmate in the corner
of the board
this one it's almost game over let's go
back to the players it's black breaking
through to the white king wow magnus
carlson about to win the air things
masters if janna pognashe isn't able to
come up with something
incredible and he is capable but a
hundred on the bar
sometimes the position is just not good
enough you know you might be the best
player in the world but your position is
just dire and there's nothing to do
and unfortunately
barring
something going terribly wrong for
magnus here it's going to be game over
because
there's just no defense to queen takes
pawn check and if you do try to defend
against it well there's simply going to
be
i don't see it actually
yep there's no way no way computer
confirms it plus 100 that means
checkmate is about to happen
janna pomericki just raising his
eyebrows down under three minutes is he
about to resign
no way to continue no he looks so sad
yeah oh nothing else to do checkmate
coming in the next few moves it'll be
nice to see on the board that will be a
fitting way to end such a fighting
tournament but uh either way heartbreak
for napomniacci who's been so good the
whole event
magnus just taking his chances today
right yeah it just kind of feels like
the stories followed like once narrative
like napoleon was so dominant in the
opening and then one misstep
and the kind of the whole situat the
whole
momentum has changed for magnus and
magnus takes over
it's just
i mean chess is so harsh
just one slip one wrong move in a
promising position and suddenly your
opponent has everything
and magnus still focused still
calculating but by this point he knows
that he's about to win things masters
and okay magnus just waiting for the
hammer to fall
napoli actually about to resign about to
give up
okay
moments away from the trophy
and what a hard fought and fantastic
final by ana pognati we know he's been
under a lot of pressure a lot of things
has been on his mind it must have been
hard to focus he has played some
fantastic games
but there it is
it ends here magnus carlsen winning two
games today he is the winner of the air
things master after an incredible final
with a great janna pomnyacci by magnus
carlson showing
his genius in this final we've had
incredible fight